j'accueille olivier adria troupes
un beau matin vous vous apprêtez à
sortie a gagné coup d'oeil au miroir un
petit coup de peigne et toi d'époux
panique même si c'est des années par un
fou ça n'a jamais mangé personne c'est
juste un petit insecte qui s'installent
sur notre cuir chevelu pour cible un
frais tranquillement de sa nourriture
préférée le sang le pot n'a pas d'elle
et ne saute pas mais il est en revanche
gratuite et un simple contact de bonnets
et écharpes par exemple lui suffit pour
changer de tête il faut donc être
vigilant 6 agathon et si ça chatouille
passer tout de suite vos cheveux open
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
olivia adriaco à biarritz où elle passe
aujourd'hui la moitié de son temps
on est sur la grande plage de biarritz
enfin en tous les cas on y va le rituel
du matin c'est la balade avec son chien
et nous annonce du mauvais temps on a du
beau temps enfin c'est toujours un point
contraire est en tout cas ça peut
vraiment changer dans la journée
le matin il fait beau et puis l'après
midi ça va être un peu couvert ça va se
dégager demain il va refaire 30 degrés
dans tous les cas la température est
bonne et tout est loin de paris olivia
continue d'aimer l'agitation de la ville
à biarritz elle a ses habitudes de
quartier
alors on va au bar du marché
des grands soirs non mais t'as fait une
belle acquisition ça parle bien et c'est
vous
ce matin sur un marché à la brocante
après ces frappes a dit long
ah oui est ce trop
un regard des petites trouvailles
ffct course j'ai vu toi c'est
ainsi qu'a fait d'abord ouais tout à
fait la rencontre et simplement comme
ici ce matin autour d'un autour d'un
café avec des amis on avait en commun
c'est quelqu'un a cédé assez complexe et
très intéressante aux chiens oui tous
les wars chaque fois j'ai besoin de
courses à vrai dire j'achète plus du
franc est joué oil way
dix commerçants ça j'aime bien il ya une
bonne ambiance et plus dimanche matin
c'est assez sympa question cuisine
olivia aussi ses bons plans est-ce qu'il
est là
alors ici on fait la queue pour manger
la meilleure andouille vaut mieux
arriver tôt parce que généralement
ouais c'est un polo et puis quand la
pluie surtout
pas tenu longtemps pâle sourire
habitat tao
oui ça va faire un petit coucou
à ça fait un petit moment je suis en
répétition tu sais je chante
il faut que j'apprenne démenti
dans les landes olivia se sent bien à
l'écart de la télé proche du terroir en
toute simplicité
c'est vraiment
c'est fait
dans cette ancienne ferme ayant
appartenu à luis mariano à deux minutes
de biarritz olivia s'adonne à son
plaisir favori l'équitation
salut ma beauté
à l'état
[Musique]
l'ua la rolls on est le propriétaire de
ce haras bien c'est une très bonne
cavalière
passionné bien sûr et
mon amoureux du dressage et d'une rave
ou des choux ibérique
aujourd'hui olivier fille adoptive de la
région est devenue la marraine du pôle
eau du pays basque un polo entre copains
comme m
[Applaudissements]
on est
l'autre passion d'olive hier c'est la
musique à son actif elle a déjà deux
albums et prépare depuis une semaine un
concert à l'atabal une salle réputée de
biarritz
chn
[Musique]
non moi et tu veux copains d'accord je
te croise même des normes se lèche
hélène est là pour ans que les deux
guitares y aura encore la batterie et tu
vas arriver trop bien
la musique qu'elle y consacre
aujourd'hui toute son énergie au
contraire moins certain
m
à biarritz la carrière d'olivia s'écrit
désormais sur un autre air
et maintenant la lumière se rallume sur
olivia adriaco
bienvenue sur plateau de tout le monde à
part et olivia alors vous n'êtes ni le 5
février 1966 à paris père d'origine
italienne
qui vendait des machines à écrire les
dictaphones
et votre mère travailler avec lui en
fait cela fait quand même quatre enfants
à s'occuper de filles deux garçons alors
très jeune le théâtre vous vous attire à
14 ans vous entré au conservatoire d'art
dramatique pour préparer la rue blanche
mais votre passion pour la chanson
prendra le dessus au grand mère adorée
la chanson dont elle chantait dans les
cours les cours d'immeuble est né en
1924 est toujours là et elle disait à
votre bon coeur messieurs dames et elle
attendait les festons c'était toujours
surtout pour le plaisir de chanter alors
dès l'âge de 16 ans vous décidez d'être
chanteuse ou tout du moins de vivre de
votre voix vous fait des pubs ou fait
dessins animés vous être choriste et à
17 ans vous enregistrez votre premier
disque en fait un 45 tours de reprise
s'annonce pas trop j'ai c'est un premier
duo avec alain sanders et
voilà tournée radio monte carlo quand
même mais bon tout petit succès iron eti
alors là vous refaites choristes de
cette fois avec dave avec carlos avec
gilbert montagne est
donc là c'est en suivant les tournées
radio monte carlo et
donc bien tout simplement c'était les
artistes du podium allait coiffer
réceptive la tournure pas à tourner
et j'ai d'excellents souvenirs parce que
c'était très marrant
hélas en 1990 ou fait de la plongée au
mexique et vous rencontrer le
réalisateur de taratata gérard pollicino
qui vous parle de m6 la petite chaîne
qui monte chercher des animateurs et
vous conseille de faire un casting alors
j'étais un peu surprise parce que la
télévision pour moi c'était vraiment une
inconnue totale et d'ailleurs j'ai raté
mon premier casting
j'ai raconté d'histoires drôles parce
que sur m6 y avait pas grand monde qui
s'occupe de ça à l'époque et il m'a dit
c'est pas grave y'a l'un à l'autre et il
a du coup j'ai
ouï voila voila j'ai commencé à
m'entraîner livre une caméra et puis bon
j'ai été sélectionné il y en avait 10
ans garçons cinq filles pour présenter
ses émissions musicales vous aviez envie
sur la télévision non non pas du tout je
suis allée comme personne voilà parce
que quand il m'a proposé ça j'ai trouvé
ça un peu incongru et puis m'aider me
cherche des filles comme toi tu verras
c'est pas compliqué et puis du mexique
je te rappellerai puis finalement il l'a
fait donc c'est un peu grâce à lui
finalement jamais il c'est toute votre
carrière c'est à ce que vous avez fait
beaucoup de télévision me sont vraiment
être fan de ça et on voulait en faire de
la chanson en fait oui et puis enfin
quand la télévision au départ
c'était c'était un peu spécial pour moi
je vois là je sais pas trop ce que je
faisais là ce qui allait se passer
j'avais une petite émission en direct
voilà vous aviez hittites pourra pas
facile il ya
destination musique six nations en
vacances les matins d'olivia et puis
surtout pendant trois ans haute forme
j'étais pas mal c'était une super
émission c'était tout à fait novateur
l'écran coupée en deux avec la bonne et
la mauvaise olivia sur les petits bobos
quotidiens et il y avait plein de
petites choses vraiment ingénieuse rex
et saynètes way or autre truc c'est la
chanson d'ailleurs en 1996 toujours
gérard pullicino vous propose de
remplacer nagui taratata
et là vous voulez pas pourquoi eh bien à
votre forme démarrer vraiment et en plus
de ça je dis à nagui d'avoir ça être
difficile de que je m'assois dans ton
fauteuil
la deuxième chose c'est que je serai
jamais invité dans cette émission
et si alexandra kazan qui s'y est collé
voilà vous avez regretté sa non non non
non non j'ai pas été finalement alors
vous restez sur m6 vous fait pourquoi ça
marche avec laurent weil oui mais vous
n'avez pas oublié votre vocation
première en
1999 vous montez sur scène à nouveau et
là vous dites grâce à la télé je n'ai
plus le souci de gagner ma vie avec la
chanson en même temps près de gagner
l'argent rater si vous n'êtes plus
obligé de réussir la chanson aussi non
alors moi c'est pas ces deux points je
faisais pas de la musique pour une
histoire de notoriété est ce que ma tête
à la télévision je la voyais donc
c'était juste que voilà c'est une une
fois quelque chose qu'il faut travaille
avec des choses que vous avez envie
d'exprimer et la musique pour moi c'est
c'était simplement le plaisir et le
bonheur de chanter d'être essentielle
enfin que ce n'était pas le problème
qu'on me reconnaisse ou pas
alors vous avez des chansons à ce moment
là faisait beaucoup de mal à les
enregistrer et vous constatez que le
fait de vous appeler olivia adriaco
finalement ça vous aide pas mais non
c'est saïd pas forcément c'est à dire
que évidemment vous reçoit mais on vous
propose sérieux parce que il ya beaucoup
de gens de la télévision qui veulent se
lancer dans une autre carrière notamment
la musique et ça complique un peu les
choses et puis surtout j'ai pas un
répertoire je dirais entre ligne
extrêmement populaire mais c'est ça
attire les gens de la télé qui font de
la chanson ces trucs faciles c'est de la
dance et de la variet vous c'est du pop
rock donc c'est compliqué voilà c'est
quelque chose d'un petit peu plus
sérieux un petit peu plus lourd
entreprendre et puis ça coûte cher aussi
donc c'est un gros investissement la
part des maisons de disques aussi ya un
pari un petit peu lourd d'investir ce
quelqu'un la télévision va là dans ce
domaine là donc vous voulez faire la
chanson mais pourtant vous céder aux
sirènes de tf1 qui vous propose vidéo
gag pourquoi
eh bien vous aviez pas de télé chez vous
n'aviez jamais vu vidéo gag
ici j'avais déjà vidéo gag mais
je ne sais pas pourquoi
voilà la première fois j'ai refusé ouais
avant et puis la deuxième fois j'ai dit
bon pourquoi pas on verra bien ouais et
puis ça a duré vous dites je en fait
j'ai pas quitter m6 pour l'argent c'est
pas mon genre je gagnais très bien ma
vie sur m6 en fait à gagner mieux s'ils
réussissent que sur thiès oui votre
famille il a bien vécu tout ça oui que
vos potes au boeuf veau pas trop coeur
de boeuf il est habitué ouais oui oui
c'est à pisser de me voir déjà depuis
depuis un certain nombre d'années donc
non ça passe a pas changé grand chose
quelles ont été vos rapports avec les
médias je trouve que les choses se
soient un petit peu plus compliqué bon
j'étais moi je faisais vraiment partie
de la chaîne j'avais un contrat de
chaînes sur m6 mais après quand je suis
arrivée sur tf1 c'est la première fois
que je travaillais avec des producteurs
indépendants donc là les rapports sont
un petit peu différent et
c'était pas ne s'était pas du tout la
même le même sentiment on a du mal à
s'exprimer on a du mal à dire ce qu'on
veut voilà on suit une espèce j'ai
contrôlé en fait on est contrôlé oui on
est contrôlé l'argent c'est gagner de
l'argent à ce moment là oui j'ai bien
gagné ma gynéco mais bon quart d'heure
encore
et l'amour est à vous ces deux
célébrités ça a tiré des garçons
j'étais déjà en main en fin de compte
quand je suis arrivée sur m6 donc
c'était le papa de ma cible
et puis après quand j'ai quitté m6 j'ai
rencontré quelqu'un dans la musique et
voilà et puis mon belle histoire
continue toujours ah oui d'accord donc
en fait vous avez pu beaucoup d'
aventure dans votre vie non la
télévision nous a pas apporté énormément
d'histoires d'amour bon bah je pense que
si j'avais voulu j'aurais pu mais voilà
je suis sûr qu'elle était le meilleur
moment de toute cette époque toute
l'époque du vinyle détourné radio
monte-carlo de ses tournées où on
partait deux mois et demi qu'est ce que
j'ai pu rigoler voila voila on vraiment
là ça
vraiment je pense que ça reviendra plus
jamais et j'ai gardé d'excellents
souvenirs également de m6 voilà deux
oui c'était formidable et le pire moment
de la télévision au bas je dirais que
c'était plutôt après
vous dites on n'obtient pas toujours
l'émission idéal qu'on veut présenter ça
aurait été quoi l'émission idol que vous
vouliez présenter
j'étais bien sur votre forme ouais
j'aurais bien et j'ai été assez surprise
que ça s'arrête en fin de compte c'était
plus une histoire de
bise entre le producteur et la chaîne
qui ne concernait pas
cette émission était assez idéal
j'aurais bien continué dans cette source
mal à rester dans magazine alors là on
vous voit plus sur les grandes chaînes
mais vous continuez à faire de la
musique quand vous dites je ne suis pas
pressé de toute façon je crois qu'une
carrière n'ai jamais arrêté donc vous
persévérez magie la tête du
gvt de dire oui je continue toujours et
disent que sortira en 2004 financé par
vous oui sur un label que vous créez
vous et comme c'est très personnel ça ça
n'a pas un grand succès populaire faut
bien le dire mais c'est très difficile
je voulais pas qu'on affiche une
étiquette voilà parce qu'effectivement
m6 avait proposé aussi à l'époque il
avait monté avec les disques etc bon je
voulais pas avoir cette étiquette de
chaîne je voulais pas non plus d'avoir
avec une autre chaîne et donc je voulais
vraiment je n'avais pas envie qu'on me
dise voilà tu dois chanter si les tu
vois ça comme ci comme ça donc je
voulais être comme j'avais envie d'être
aidé dans mon costume bien taillé comme
il se voit donc
j'aurai ce qu'avait tête et donc après
vidéo gag vous travaillez sur vivolta en
fait une mission de ma maison sur nt1
aussi
aujourd'hui vous êtes nostalgique de
cette époque
nostalgique oui c'est le bon wen oui je
la regrette pas mais c'est vrai que ça
reste mon souvenir mais je suis contente
aussi que les choses prennent une autre
tournure
si c'était à refaire alors est-ce que
vous accepteriez pas un contrat même si
ce music ou deux est-ce que vous
mettriez pas un petit peu plus d'eau
dans votre vin ça vous croyez que j'ai
vu c'est un an m aveu
je sais pas
non je pense que j'ai vécu son pour
santé j'ai envie de faire 100% musique
maintenant je vais en tous les cas
essayer d'aller dans ce sens là le jour
vous allez mourir que je voulais qu'on
mettre sur votre vote retombées qu'on
écrive vous allez monter en ce gentil
merci c'est très heureux de rallumer la
glace en volume revient sur cette série
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu